milk is quite possibly one of the most
successful YouTube channels in existence
Their audience spans into the tens of
millions across platforms they routinely
sell millions of dollars a month in
March they've created a 250 million
dollar beverage Empire through happy Dad
and today we get to sit down and talk
money with the man behind the billion
dollar business John Shahidi enjoy
although before we go into that we gotta
thank today's sponsor fund and grow like
I'm sure you've all seen the show Shark
Tank well they're a perfect example of
how even if you have the best business
in the world expanding can be nearly
impossible without the proper funding
but thankfully you don't have to go on a
TV show to get the funding your business
needs just use today's sponsor fun and
grow fund and grow is a unique funding
alternative with far fewer restrictions
than traditional bank loans with their
12-month membership you can access up to
250 000 of credit at zero percent
interest all while retaining full equity
in your company and don't just take our
word for it over 4 000 customers have
given fund and grow 4.9 star reviews and
as a special offer for our listeners fun
girls prepared a business funding master
class that uncovers the five simple
steps to securing up to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in business
credit plus as an exclusive bonus you'll
receive a 500 discount on their services
so don't wait to fund and grow your
business visit fund and grow today using
the link Down Below in the description
thank you so much fun and grow and now
on to the podcast so like if there's
anything you want out of it it's gonna
go out in a while yeah you have time
I'll just double check the 250 million
dollar valuation thing I said yeah I
mean Kyle said it if he said it and it's
already out there then yeah it's just I
remember everyone was kind of pissed
that he said it everyone was like yo why
they say that like and then you know is
everybody out there because that main
Channel video would probably go out on
Monday I don't know where he said it I
know people were freaking out he said it
somewhere and then so we just said it on
a podcast or something yeah I forgot
which one I don't know Theo Vaughn I
don't know Theo Von I love theoven
that's my bet my favorite podcast man
really this past weekend yeah yeah
that's Graham doesn't know who video is
and I've been trying to get him on the
podcast first yeah he said he's going to
be in Vegas in a bit yeah we're gonna
shoot with him when he comes to Vegas
you're talking to him yes okay yeah why
was his so good oh he's just a great
pocket are we going yeah oh we are sure
yeah we're good all right great
um no he's just my favorite like there's
he's he's unique he's funny yeah
um but he's also one of those things
like you gotta like under like you gotta
be ready for his humor right like yeah
I've seen him say some things where the
guests like didn't get it and I'm like
dude really like he just said something
funny you're not laughing like it just
goes over your head like yeah it's one
of those things he's just so nervous
though no you gotta you gotta know Theo
to understand his type of humor yeah
yeah he's he's the best in my opinion
he's the greatest podcaster period why
yeah like he's the like I love Joe Rogan
yeah you know and obviously I love
everything we do but like when it comes
to like you know outside of our world
like if I want to like listen and I'm
boys with Theo but there's never a day
that I want to work with him ever just
because like I'm such a fan like I'm
just a big fan I met him he came to our
holidays a happy Dad holiday party I was
[__] nervous man really yeah yeah I
was nervous I would imagine yeah I was
nervous and I almost asked him for a
picture and then um
what's the guy's name
tall guy that dated Addison Ray's mom oh
yeah young grave young gravy that dude
comes up and he just he gives me his
phone he's like will you take a picture
of me and Theo I'm like oh yeah so I
took a picture of him at Theo and I was
like this is my chance and I didn't but
then like but me and him became boys and
obviously like I hope Kyle get on the
podcast it's like yo you got to get Kyle
on and Drew ski I was like you got to
get Drew ski on but uh that Drew skip
episode was amazing yeah I love that
episode but there were some things that
went over drewsky's head and that's
that's a comedian too that's a stand-up
comic himself Drew so what sort of jokes
though going over people's heads yeah
it'd be so hard to say man I mean I'm
sure people listening that they know
theoven they know what I'm talking about
it's I've tried I've tried to explain
like I've told my brother I've told my
wife like hey there was this one part
where Theo said this and like they just
didn't laugh the delivery is not yeah
you just have to hear it and you have to
know Theo it's like the the Deep South
type comedy where he goes on these super
long-winded jokes super descriptive
things that you feel like just
definitely didn't happen her childhood
stories about this dude yeah
do you think about that like some of
them I'm like dude there's no way like
with these I make it up I I that's one
thing I don't but some of them sound I
mean he is from Louisiana I've heard a
lot of the stories are exaggerated not
yeah you're him that's what I would
other companies but he sounds like a
real story like they'll expand on it
yeah yeah but he says so genuine it
sounds like he doesn't need to I wonder
if he just has had a crazy life and just
ran into some crazy experiences yeah I
don't know I love him though man I love
theovani yeah biggest fan we're gonna
have him on we gotta dude I can't wait
for you guys to have them on that's me
awesome I'll be watching it's free it's
on him right now so whatever he's in
Vegas next we'll make it happen yeah
yeah yeah he's on tour right yeah yeah
so what exactly is your title within the
whole full send franchise um I'm the
president of all Ventures so the
president of all Ventures so full send
no happy Dad
um shots podcast Network all Ventures so
you're the president of this beverage
right here yes correct you all may
notice we have alcoholic beverages on
the uh camera right now and Graham and I
we don't drink very often I think we've
now have we had a drink on a podcast
before maybe once or twice I don't think
so okay no I don't think so openly well
we're about to try discreet about it I
have had a happy Dad once before I think
I I gently sipped it maybe at Graham's
house or something and we're gonna
review it apparently the fruit punch is
the the best flavor it's the most
popular right now but also let's be
clear we weren't planning on drinking I
had my coffee no either no and then you
wanted to you should bring over it no
this is all grams you said you were
going to shotgun it I did not say that
you sent Russ Big Russ to go grab them I
was perfectly fine with the coffee
we have to I mean you're the president
of a massive company right this is the
product and I would love to let's do it
I mean I would love I'd be honest with
you guys you started you and we'll join
you halfway through okay all right let's
listen Brian knows what's up though yeah
okay nice crack
how is it
wow wow that tastes like a Gatorade it
actually tastes like a mildly alcoholic
Gatorade that's one thing um should I
have said that or is that a bad thing to
say no I don't think it's okay to say
um
no one thing we take pride in in this
and a lot of different products that
we're coming out with whether it's new
flavors or other consumer good products
is we're very good with taste like we're
like we have a pretty like everyone here
is brutally honest from like our
operations team to even
Stephen Kyle like when it's time to
taste test something like No One's Gonna
settle and we'll go back and forth a
dozen times if we need to to have that
perfect taste it honestly hardly tastes
like there's alcohol in that and I gotta
chill out with it because I just I you
know any yeah um water whatever I just
yeah I mean it's lighter on the Alcohol
side it's only five percent but no it's
it's actually it's really nice it tastes
like cotton candy yeah that's cool so
John I was curious what was your first
job how did you get started in all this
well first job or how did I get started
first job okay like take us back to the
very beginning so the beginning was like
first job was different first job was
high school yeah McDonald's yeah like
yeah so I worked at McDonald's six when
I was 16 that was my first job
um
I think uh I'm very grateful for it
because I learned how to cook I worked
in the kitchen and um and now like I'm I
grill a mean burger and I really think
it's from then like I don't really know
how to cook much else other than what's
on the barbecue and it's no coincidence
I worked at McDonald's first job and now
everybody loves my burgers at the house
so so yeah that was the first job
um but that was when I was 16 then fast
forward to maybe about 10 years later
is when we um when me and my brother
started
what's now shots podcast network is our
pretty much our YouTube Network you know
in 2000 I always get the years mixed up
I think it was end of 2008 so that's why
we say 2009 I must say it was like
November 2008 so so really it was 2009
by the time everything got up and
running uh we created a YouTube Network
um we wanted to get people that we knew
um onto YouTube like maybe like more
like athletes people in the world of
sports and
um and back then there wasn't any other
social media outside of YouTube you know
Facebook was out but Facebook was very
private mostly schools there was no
public profiles on Facebook yeah there
was no Instagram yet there was no snap
um Twitter was out
um Twitter had just come out I want to
say it was brand brand new so those were
really the two social media Outlets was
YouTube and
Twitter so so that's you know I've
always had a passion for YouTube
YouTube's always been my thing what did
you see in it back then because back
then a lot of people were dismissive
about it it was really just these like
random one-off viral videos there
weren't really any channels that people
would follow not really influencers no
no no no no back then was like Charlie
bit my finger I think that was like what
YouTube was known for
um you know
so so in between McDonald's and this it
was like probably a 10-year window
11-year window and um
um we had another company that was an
agency for DirecTV we did DirecTV
Outsource our agency to come up with
Creative Marketing for them mostly
around the NFL Sunday Ticket the
football program and um so we would
always do market research on who would
DirecTV customers how directive is
growing where DirecTV is growing
um competition which was mostly uh the
cable industry or or Dish Network at the
time uh but there was always this like
every quarter there was always this like
this um
this competitor that was growing it was
always categorized as other and like
other was like one percent one to two
percent three percent four percent and
what other was Internet TV and was
YouTube You Know YouTube was but like no
one cared and I always asked wait what
is other don't worry about other you
know we're going after cable we're going
after Dish Network
so that's when I said all right there's
something growing here people are going
to start watching things online people
are going to start streaming uh you know
the iPhone had just come out around then
a couple years later the iPad came out
and that's I think I forgot the years
man but I'm gonna say the iPad came out
like 2011 2010 and that's when we're
like all right this is a thing like
people are gonna start creating content
on the internet and they're probably
going to do it mostly on YouTube
um
we got to be we got to learn this
business so by YouTube Network do you
mean more like a management company
where you find people that you think
would be good for YouTube for the
influencer space and then you start
making YouTube videos for them producing
them and stuff um so I think um
managements yeah I think it's like more
managing the channel like educating
people on how to get on YouTube you know
you guys know this too it's like it's
not easy to onboard onto YouTube
creating your first video is not easy
creating creating accounts easy
everyone's got an account you know if
you've got a Gmail account you have a
YouTube account but doing that first
upload is not easy what do I upload when
do I upload and now it's like you know
fast forwarded 2023 is like
how often do I upload what days do I
upload how long does the content have to
be how do I collaborate cross promote
break into other how do I get it's you
know because at the end of the day man
like us you guys it's always US versus
the algorithm what is the algorithm
looking for
although before we go into that we gotta
thank our sponsor as I was saying Graham
building your credit score is something
you should be doing as early as possible
but maybe you're a college student and
you don't like the idea of getting a
credit card and taking on extra debt
Jack you know I'm not in college what
are you talking about well Graham with
today's sponsor Fizz you can build your
credit without having to worry about the
debt that comes with it wait are we
filming right now who turned the cameras
on Graham stick to the script and just
tell them how Fizz Works um well Fizz is
the debit card that builds credit and
earns cash back they give you a credit
limit based on the money in your bank
account and with their autopay feature
your bill is paid off automatically
every month another really cool thing
Graham is that fizz makes their money
entirely off of merchant interchange not
from their card holders so you can enjoy
all of the benefits without any hidden
fees or charges this reports your
activity to all three major credit
bureaus helping you build your credit
score the same way as a normal credit
card would no credit check security
deposit or co-signers required so sign
up for Fizz today and you can instantly
get it on Apple pay plus you'll receive
a beautiful first edition Fizz card
shipped right to you you and if you want
some free money as an exclusive offer
the first one thousand people that sign
up with the code iced coffee get ten
dollars for free so don't miss out on
the offer the link is down below in the
description and now let's get to the
podcast one of the other things that we
had in the past was um during DirecTV is
we did a lot of the Google marketing for
DirecTV so I learned the Google
algorithm and how to SEO Pages for
DirecTV and we just knew how Google
worked and when Google bought YouTube it
was pretty much
the same
um kind of the same formula for
discoverability I don't know if the same
teams are writing the algorithm but
um they're very I mean it's it's pretty
clear that they're exchanging notes so
that's one thing that we've all we
learned at DirecTV and once we started
realizing wait a minute like we're
learning YouTube but this is actually
pretty easy and everyone's saying well
it's not that easy like how do you get
here how do you get that how do you rank
um get ranked and then we realize like
this those same things that help you
rank on Google are the same ones that
help you rank on YouTube so you
basically studied the analytics how to
be successful on YouTube provided all of
the infrastructure and logistical
support for people you thought would be
good on YouTube and that was the the
network you were building yeah yeah so
we would look in the very beginning we
would still look at
who were some of the most searched
people on YouTube
um obviously there were big names at the
time you know I don't remember who but
you know I'm sure you know whoever was
famous and popular in 2008 2009
um but there were also but who were in
our world that we knew who were the
classics
um and I knew Mike Tyson so a lot of
people search Mike Tyson on YouTube Mike
Tyson Knockouts Mike Tyson funny moments
Mike Tyson hangover scene
and I said right people are already
searching for Mike they're finding all
this old content what if we created new
content while they're searching Mike and
had these this content rank higher so we
started creating content with Mike Tyson
now how did you know Mike Tyson where
does that come from Mike I met so Floyd
Mayweather was someone else as well
people would watch Floyd Mayweather
fights and uh same thing Floyd
Mayweather like he had a show on
Showtime at HBO at the time and his
Clips would be all over YouTube so
people you know and he would say crazy
things
so people were searching Floyd maywether
so we launched Floyd's Channel
and
um there was a lady Tammy Brooke who
represented Mike and she was interested
in working with Floyd
so she reached out to me I was pretty
much the point of contact for Floyd and
um it's pretty much hey like you know
I'd love to meet Floyd I work with Mike
Tyson I was like oh well actually I got
something for Mike like what do you
think about getting Mike on YouTube and
on Twitter and she's like well you're
gonna have to talk to Mike's wife spoke
with Mike's wife uh Kiki um Kiki to this
day has become like a really good friend
of mine and she's uh it's always been a
forward thinker she's like it sounds
actually pretty interesting let's do it
so
met through this Mutual person how did
you know Floyd let's let's Circle back
for for viewers or listeners who may not
know anything about you who you are what
you do and everything yeah you were
telling me right before we turned the
cameras on that you dropped out of high
school let's tell the chronological
story from dropping out of high school
why you dropped out to getting to know
Floyd Mayweather and getting him on
YouTube yeah so I dropped out of high
school but you know
I dropped out in a kind of a bonehead
moment like I dropped out like two weeks
left of high school and I was like and
um there was like one final test I had
to take and I just didn't want to take
it like I just like I was like I didn't
like the teacher I was like I'm not
taking this test were you a good student
uh I was okay I was a stubborn student
like I was like I don't know what was
wrong with me man honestly like when I
think of myself back then like I was a
stubborn student I was stubborn athlete
like I was really good at sports but I
didn't show up to practice like I don't
know what are you doing otherwise I I I
just wanted to get out of that world and
start a business like that's all I ever
wanted I wanted to start my like I
wanted to own a business is what I
wanted to do and I had this idea and
this Vision you know I was I was going
to high school in the late 90s cell
phones were becoming popular people were
buying cell phones and then cell phones
were had become a reasonable price like
a price where a price point where
someone that wasn't super rich and
driving a Ferrari could afford and you
know I think Nokia's you know Nokia
phones that come out and like they broke
the 200 price point and I was like dude
all my friends are gonna buy cell phones
soon and they're gonna end up with a
phone number I want to establish
everyone's phone numbers I want to get
them all cell phones I want to be the
guy I want to be the plug for cell
phones because and then so I went to um
at that time it was Pacific Bell
Wireless that turned into singular and
now it's become a t and I pretty much
did a deal with them I said hey I I'm
gonna sign up hundreds of people in
Orange County for cell phone service
um I want a commission for every single
person and I want a percentage of the
bill where do you think that
entrepreneurial Spirit came from did you
like watch content or Media or whatever
about entrepreneurship no I've never
watched anything I was never really
content back then we're talking about
like 1998 right now so there was no
really content to watch online
um I think there was two things that
really
um kind of inspired me
one was um
always loved Steve Jobs and there was a
movie about Steve Jobs it was a
fictional movie I don't even think it
was authorized called uh Pirates of
Silicon Valley just kind of the beef
between Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
and um that was one movie I guess I
would watch that maybe inspired me but
I learned actually you know what's crazy
is like as close as I am with Mike Tyson
and all the stuff I've done with Mike
and Kiki they came to my wedding a few
months ago they were the first person
when we got married like they were
literally standing there like it was
like the most beautiful moment but
what's crazy is like I actually got my
entrepreneurship when I was younger I
used to love Mike Tyson so much but we
couldn't afford fights so I would go and
I would sell candy in elementary school
to make money and give that money to my
mom and say mom here I made 25 bucks or
30 bucks whatever it costs watched Mike
Tyson fight and I was like can we please
buy the Mike Tyson fight I'm gonna pay
for it you know I'm talking about when I
was like 11 10 11 years old we would go
to like like some of these like
Wholesale grocery stores at the time I
think it was a smart and final and I
would go and buy like a box of like
AirHeads or recess and I would buy them
and I would sell them at school and I
was like I was the candy plug at school
you know a lot of people are saying yeah
I used to sell weed when I was in high
school yeah not me I sell chocolate and
like bubble gum and and I would do it
and I wasn't doing it to make money I
was doing it really so I could watch a
Mike Tyson fight so it was just crazy as
like full circle now I've never even
told them like the story but that's like
where I think at like 10 11 years old I
got my entrepreneurship was from then
that's unreal you're getting trouble
selling candy all the kids in my school
ended up getting in trouble for that I
don't think I you know um
um I always went by the model NBC I was
NBC never been caught all right I've
never been caught I was Mr NBC really
it's funny because I feel like a lot of
the people where we ask where their
entrepreneurial Spirit came from or when
they first showed signs of it everybody
says they sold candy at school really so
if you sold candy at school we're
banking on your science for your future
we're investing yeah that's funny okay
so you decided to drop out with two
weeks left what was the next step from
from drug Next Step was uh getting this
deal with at T and they accepted it they
accepted it um how do they trust you
though because you must be like 17 just
barely turning no I was 18. yeah I was
18. I was a little older I've always
come off as like kind of a genuine guy
like you know I always you know so I uh
someone someone trusted me I I don't
really remember
um
um one thing I do do remember though I
never got the deal direct so they were
giving out licenses for like people open
up cell phone store they never got a
deal direct so I actually worked
underneath someone else
um so I was a
um there's authorized dealers then
there's sub dealer so I worked
underneath this other guy that took like
um you know he actually took care of me
he almost like passed through the entire
commission so um
so I worked Underneath Him and
um eventually to a point where I ended
up going direct with DirecTV or I'm
sorry with ATT and then later on I took
the same model to DirecTV and I said hey
like this is what I do for a t right now
I call it 18t because that's what it is
now back then was called singular
um but um
and then I yeah pretty much started
doing the same thing with DirecTV
DirecTV said hey like we want to do more
with you like you know because I was
coming up with all these ideas like like
my team which my team was me and my
brother like you know and yeah and one
other guy Aaron Mathis that works with
us um you know we we came up like you
know one of the first things we came up
with we went to the uh US postal office
and we said Hey what if we put like
flyers in on inside the envelopes when
someone moves when they're doing mail
forwarding and we'll pay for the
envelopes We're not gonna pay for that
but we'll pay for the envelope so we'll
take that expense of the envelopes off
your plate but when someone moves we
want a flyer in there now now you get it
all the time it's like when you move you
get like alarm service local landscaping
and all that stuff but we were the first
people to ever do that with DirecTV
because that's one of the first things
people do when they move they turn on
electricity water gas
television service yep that's
interesting because nowadays I feel like
the landscape is completely different
like if I want if I came up with some
way to improve Amazon or something like
that I can't just like go and start
working for them as a contractor or
something like that or have a some
affiliate I guess I could do with like
Amazon Affiliates and stuff like that
yeah but I feel like it's just different
it's more detached I mean the internet's
different because now you have a lot of
competition because almost anyone could
build an Amazon store could create a
brand on Instagram or Tick Tock or
Twitter whatever
um but now it's more about like what are
you doing to really stand out more
um but yeah I mean like you guys for
instance like think about it like you
guys Stand Out far more than most
podcasters you know it's like you guys
are obviously doing something different
so it's just the internet's really
changed things you know back then this
is this is like the internet first came
out but we're talking about web one you
know like you know this is like
the websites that were relevant I don't
like I don't even know if Google was out
yet or Google had just come out like you
know I'm talking about like
Yahoo eBay Amazon those days you know
how much were you making back doing uh
you know DirecTV at T you know I've
always had this
good problem where whatever I made I put
back into the business which is where
we're at today too so um it's hard to
say like what I profited but you know I
made it good enough money you know um
eventually we opened up stores so
overhead was there you know started
racking up you know uh stores inside
retail shopping centers next to because
our thing was we want to open up stores
next to
grocery stores so um and they're in
Orange County so like you know now
you're talking about rent you're talking
about employees Staffing insurance and
were you just bringing people in to sign
them up for DirecTV
direct little cell phone so we had the
cell phone stores and then the cell
phone stores happen to sell DirecTV as
well got it yeah okay and did they have
any problem with just kind of some
random guy opening up a store with their
branding with their name and everything
oh they allowed it so essentially
represented them in some capacity this
was pre what you see now is almost all
the stores you see are almost all
corporate owned now so back then they
actually let you
put up their sign and everything your
the window on your window you had to put
a sticker it said authorized retailer or
authorized dealer
um but the signage they actually
encouraged you they actually paid for
our signs or our signs outside of our
buildings also singular and they
actually would reimburse us to put their
logos out eventually they bought out
most of us and almost everyone I was a
dealer and almost all the stores you see
now were initially
um dealer stores or retailers you know
sub uh authorized retailers but um
there's always this like word like some
some didn't like being called dealer so
they call this retailers I I was always
it was like 20 years ago I'm still
confused on what we were called but
eventually they came and bought us all
out and that's when they started when
they started buying us out
um because if you didn't sell to them
they would open up a store across the
street from you oh okay so we were like
all right we're just then they could
undercut because they don't have to pay
the commission yeah but then like now
they launched their website and the
website you know nearest store they
didn't put your address they put their
address so they would do little that and
to a point I was like I don't know if I
want to play this game it's around its
course it's been like five or six years
now
DirecTV wants to do all this other stuff
with us now the marketing NFL Sunday
Ticket again in the World of Sports the
World of Sports has been something that
I've always been the most fascinated
with
um so I was like I want to be in the
World of Sports and if DirecTV is going
to let us do the marketing for NFL
Sunday Ticket and you know a lot of like
the like we created the whole the entire
strategy of DirecTV and bars was
something that me and my brother created
so when you now see UFC or football
games at the bar you see like a giant
sign at a bar it says NFL Sunday Ticket
carried here we created that whole model
for them and so
to me that's the business I wanted to be
in and so DirecTV let us do that so they
kind of gave us an open checkbook
they're like we we trust that you're
going to do this right you know the only
thing we ask is focus on concentrating
markets
which is funny which is where we're at
now with DirecTV he's like focus on
existing markets own those markets and
go one market at a time so and we'll
talk about how happy that is doing that
same thing and it's like you know one
might ask why you're in 16 States not
all so I kind of go on that DIRECTV
model that we had learned is like
focusing on certain markets owning those
markets and then opening up market after
market so did you end up selling those
cell phone stores back to the the
companies can you say how much you were
selling them for
I haven't it wasn't much it wasn't any I
don't even remember but you had to be
doing well right for them to like but it
wasn't a crazy money it was enough money
low million so like it wasn't like crazy
money it was like maybe two million
dollars or something like that two
million yeah yeah I think it's like 300
Grand yeah when you were saying like it
wasn't crazy I was like what like 200
Grand yeah no no we were crushing it we
were no I would imagine yeah we were
crushing and we could have been a lot
bigger but we just did but that was the
passion and you said you were cycling
everything back into the business so you
were growing I would still that's pretty
substantial but then again after tax
yeah
if you trim down the overhead and
everything which I'm sure you could have
and didn't cycle it all back you
probably could have taken a pretty hefty
profit
probably
the the problem was the passion was in
there and to me like if the passion is
not there I don't give a [__] what it is
you know like
like I don't remember the exact number
to be honest because like I just didn't
care about that business I wanted to get
in this world of sports really bad like
I wanted to get in which goes through
the question of like how did you meet
Mayweather I wanted to be in the World
of Sports and DirecTV was allowing me to
so I wanted to do that but I'm curious
because you were in your 20s at this
point how in your 20s did you justify
putting everything back into the
business versus just like I'm gonna take
some money out I'm gonna have a great
time I'm gonna Live It Up definitely had
a great time and lived it up that's for
sure like yeah I did you know but living
it up is a little different you know
like I'm living it up right now like you
know I mean like like when you guys said
like you know we're setting up I'm like
you have anything else like no like I'm
living it up today like living it up to
me is like a simple life I've always
been a minimalist so living it up to me
is a little bit different than most
people sure
um so I mean I still had a good time you
know I was in my 20s uh you know the
house I wanted you know I've always been
a simple guy when it comes to
automobiles like I've never been a
sports car guy so like I think I got a
um Chevy Tahoe at the time that was like
my dream car got it you know so like
what do you drive now I have an Escalade
so it's like a Tahoe but yeah little you
know but that's all I drive you know
Steve's always like dude if you like
SUVs you should get the SUV Bentley no
like well one is I'm very loyal to GM
like I'm like it's got to be a GM
product so I've only driven
he would be fantastic man I saw one at
the gym the other day everybody looked
tempted yeah I saw one at the gym the
other day I'm just the only time I'm
gonna probably switch from GM is when
cyber truck comes out okay sure so I
don't I don't want to you know and by
the way the Hummer right now is like I
called my buddy Rd from my wires only I
was like how much are they they're like
they're a hundred thousand over sticker
am I doing
back to them yeah I'm not paying 100
like I don't want it that bad like
that's pretty sick I mean mine is
filling up gas but
Fair yeah yeah yeah so anyway so how do
you get in sports from all of this like
you sold these businesses why did you
want to go to the next thing didn't did
any part of you just want to say Hey you
know let me just chill for a little bit
I got some cash in the bank I don't need
much
no no I wanted to when I when I want to
do something like there's no stopping
like it's no cash no nothing like when I
wanna you know when I got like going
back to the high school thing right like
I dropped out with two weeks left
because I want to start this business so
when I want to start something like
there's nothing I don't know if it's OCD
I don't know what it is but once
something triggers like I can't undo it
and I have to go get it done so what was
that thing for you when it comes to
sports
being in the world of
football and NFL like now like you know
with doing all this marketing for
DirecTV and the Sunday Ticket like we've
got a relationship with the NFL now I
got a relationship with all the teams
um then
you know you're meeting players you're
doing like coming up with ideas for like
commercials and stuff like that like
brought in all these you know the NBA
league pass um forgot what the NASCAR
one was but there was NASCAR and like
anytime they brought on these new
leagues or these new like League
packages with with the sports leagues
like they kind of brought it put up
brought it to me like hey like listen we
just did a deal with NASCAR what do you
think about doing the marketing getting
all the bars and restaurants on board
I'm in I'm in like anything when it
comes to sports the one person I really
really looked up to like who inspired me
was Mark Cuban so I just loved Mark
Cuban I think Sports entrepreneurs in
general are like I don't know like I
feel like they're so underrated I was
thinking about that the other day like
you know when we did the um Michael
Rubin podcast I don't know if you guys
saw that with full send full sends done
one with them the pivot's done one with
them and it's like dude it's just like
sports entrepreneurs Dana White even
David Porter Dave Portner is a very very
underrated entrepreneur you know because
people look at it more of an Internet
personality than they do but like
personal Sports is pretty they sell they
sold yeah was it 550 million I don't
remember that it was like 380 for the
remaining amount but then like I don't I
don't remember what the first amount was
yeah
um whatever it is but like Barstool is
like it's so Barcelo is so powerful man
like and uh that's like I mean Portland
has got it always gives credit to his
team but like that's him like it starts
with him and then he built that team so
you know guys like him Dana White you
know
said Mark Cuban Michael Rubin like these
guys like just like sports entrepreneurs
have always been like someone I've
always looked up to
so you were selling all these it was
Cable packages with with cable and you
were doing well and you got presented
with all these different opportunities
when they came out with a NASCAR package
I'm sure a UFC package and you were
doing all the marketing for yeah all of
those new releases so they would pay us
per new subscriptions commercial
subscription so it was an affiliate yeah
so there was an affiliate side but then
on a separate side they gave us a crazy
marketing budget to create marketing
material as well for the for ourselves
but for other
um Affiliates as well so they so it was
like two businesses that we had with
DirecTV at the same time yeah and one
was telling selling the businesses one
was selling to Consumers the there was
one signing selling to businesses and
then there was one like doing the
marketing for it like oh got it
these things you know I mean like these
things like all like uh point-of-sale
items that went into the bars
um
um eventually radio ads TV ads we
oversaw the creative for that which
helped the whole empire so like you know
you so you could have been affiliate you
could have been affiliate and we had
different ways to reach out to like say
like a TGI Fridays and sign up TGI
Fridays uh first person go who got it
got the money from it and a percentage
of the bill
um but we were the ones that you would
come to as well and be like hey listen I
signed up I know I'm your competitor I
signed up TGI Fridays but do you have
any of these posters and these blow-ups
that we could give them these banners
um yeah yeah we yeah we got all those so
yeah we'll ship them out to you just
give us so we so we had like two sides
of our business the marketing side for
the bars and restaurants for sports
packages but then also like we if we
signed up that they would give you like
a bounty of like I forgot the dollar
amount probably a couple thousand
dollars per an account and and what was
crazy is 10 of the bill was crazy that's
a lot ten percent of the bill and bill
the bill was all based off fire code
occupancy when it's commercial no way
yeah so the bigger the place based off
their fire could the bigger the bill
so some of these people may have ordered
a fight for like forty five hundred
dollars you know because their bar
restaurant holds 300 400 500 people
and we would get 10 of that plus
whatever they're paying monthly for all
the other packages it's a good business
to be in it was very nice oh but it ran
its course right because
you know even though it still exists and
bars still have it
we saw that same writing on the wall we
saw what the cell phone companies wait
they're learning from us they're they're
asking me a lot of questions they're
going to eventually do this in-house
they're paying us I forgot the dollar
amount was ridiculous ridiculous made
that two million dollars nothing that's
why I don't remember it
um but
um saw the writing on the wall but also
saw this whole
growth of YouTube at the time I was like
wait a minute so they're going to screw
us meanwhile there's a competitor coming
to them and it's pretty much free
television on the internet
like we're not going to make money off
of this for a very very long time very
long time like to this day like I'm
still not making crazy money but
let's get into that business and this is
better long term the free the free uh
the free service which is YouTube so
what was your title doing being the the
marketer for cable or and there was was
there a bunch of other people doing the
same thing that you were doing
Affiliates there was a gazillion
Affiliates
um
I think we rank like top three of all
the like there was probably I don't know
a thousand it was a company that yeah it
was called direct one is was the name of
our company yeah so so we were a company
that had a contract with DirecTV and
then we did
their marketing as well separately that
was a retainer that we were on a
retainer so there was no nobody else
doing the marketing for it it was just
us for a while eventually they were
hiring people in-house to learn and ask
us questions how did you get so good at
doing that in sales
were you just naturally A salesperson
yeah I think really just learning at an
early age how to right like if I bought
a box of Reese's buttercups I had to
unload that thing I couldn't like go
back home and eat it like I mean and I
was doing that at times right and I was
a fat kid because of it like you know
because you know like you know I would
have sell I was you know so I had it
like you had to go out there and
actually like hustle and unload these
things and do two for one specials three
for one specials you know I mean like
stuff like that
um you know to unload that so I could
watch the Mike Dyson fight yeah so you
say it was just a gradual increase in
knowledge there was nothing no book you
read nothing you consumed that like
really helped you out
um I've only read two books my whole
life what books uh Charlotte's Web and
um Art of War did you like them uh
Charlie's boy was nice so sad these are
two totally opposite books you're
thinking like two business books or
something yeah Charlotte's Webb said Art
of War I think is a very good book um
it's very hard to read
um I had to re I've read friend is a
number of times but it's really hard to
understand
um so I've had to go and like kind of
break down and I actually made like my
own cliff notes of it so like now I
share it like I said Steve will do it
the other day I was like Hey like this
is a book I don't think you're gonna
understand the book it's very very hard
to read because it's translated from
Chinese from Mandarin so um
but here are some Cliff Notes what are
some of the cliff notes like what's the
big takeaway from that book that you got
I think patience yeah I think patience
um there's a lot of things in business
you know you gotta learn is um
I mean you know it's it's really based
off some military do you guys know about
it no I know of the book okay I mean
it's a lot of like Chinese military
Antics so one would be
I'm not saying a huge practice this but
I'm saying like you know
when an enemy's resting you attack
when an enemy is going crazy you rest
you know I mean and but don't let them
know you're resting you know like little
things like that when you just think
you're like damn that's [__] deep
like yeah like if you know like don't
don't react to it you know don't re
don't react to you know I mean in
today's world anime could be you know
they they worded as enemy but it could
also be you know your competitor it
could be someone you're negotiating with
it could be a distributor it could be
anything you know a retailer
um but it's all you know I think being
patient and really understanding the
world of business sitting back not not
reacting so much uh is something that
I've always learned is like I will like
I when it comes to business one thing I
don't ever do is I don't make sudden
decisions I sit back and think I don't
react to pressure
um
you know if something if someone wants
something right away
um I sit back and say why do you want it
what right away when is the right time
uh I don't believe life is short I
believe life is long think anything you
know the case of um happy Dad you know
um I think this would be a great example
is
happy dad's available in 16 States
everyone might do you got to be in all
50 states you gotta be there now and you
have to be in Canada and you have to be
in the UK and you got to be in Australia
right now like we're gonna be
in 16 States we're gonna be great at it
and we're going to launch the next five
and if it doesn't work out doesn't work
out that way well we're gonna do it that
way and we're gonna do it the slow Pro
easy way we're not gonna this is not an
overnight thing that's something I've
always learned in business in general is
like life is long life is not short like
everything's gonna work out so
it's kind of like the Apple approach
like they don't release everything super
quickly they take their time and when
they do release it they nail it you know
I think that's a very I think they've
done a very great job of
um with that model I think some of the
most successful social networks have you
done that I think like
like YouTube for instance like the
YouTube interface if you look at the
YouTube interface four years ago eight
years ago 12 years ago they all look
completely different but you almost
forget how different they look yeah you
know they make these subtle changes
right so you don't freak out because if
you make these subtle changes right away
people freak out they give their
opinions all this stuff but you know
when we make when you make drastic
changes but when you make these subtle
changes people don't really notice and
then they sit back eventually and you
let people sit and let things simmer and
that's something I've always believed in
it's like just relaxing and that's what
Art of War has taught me is like just
you know you don't need to react you
don't need to attack right away just sit
back and think about it and attack when
ready studying War tactics for business
is interesting I've heard it's a great
book for business though identifying and
capitalizing on opportunity yeah very
similar I feel like between business and
War yeah so what do you think of the way
Elon is running Twitter then because
it's like the polar opposite of you know
move calculatedly and slowly he's very
much like go 100 in this direction if it
doesn't work out you pivot you go this
direction feel good idea of some
comments I've seen a lot of these where
people have just tweeted at them hey I
think you should do this you'll respond
back actually I kind of like that yeah
we'll start doing that like the next day
it's simple yeah I think he's learned
from that you know I think he's not
doing that as much as he was when he
first bought the company and um late
October early November I think it was
making
sudden decisions and he kind of learn
that maybe that's not the move
um you know the problem
I think the difference between like
Twitter and like say like Tesla or
SpaceX is like if he has a idea for
Tesla or SpaceX they'll go to the teams
and say
hey like I got this idea for this rocket
at SpaceX and they're like oh that's a
good idea we'll come back to you in in a
year when that's done you know where
like you know here like he goes straight
to the engineers and tell him like Hey I
want to get this done done now and it's
you know and you know and it happens and
I think now I think he's realizing
because if you notice it's the rollouts
now are being thought through a lot more
so I think he's realizing wait a minute
I can't do that I got to think through
these a lot more and Twitter
um now in you know February and March
they're not making as many changes as
they were before
um drastic changes you know
um I think he's really thinking through
it I think he's realizing that because
he is a longer term thinker I don't know
if it's by choice or he has no other or
he has no other option because like you
know to come up with a new idea for a
Tesla or for SpaceX it's going to be
months and months and months like he had
no other choice but to wait six months
for a new idea for a Tesla or whatever
yeah
how did you meet Floyd Mayweather I mean
that seems like such a huge Business
Connection and to contact well that goes
back to the World of Sports right sport
that's a business I wanted to be in I
wanted to be in the World of Sports and
DirecTV led me to that you know here
there were a lot of different promo
stuff that we were doing around some of
his fights and um and we just kind of we
just met we at first we were working
through his promotions company I may
wear the promotions and then eventually
um
you know I think he just somehow some
way somebody had told him about me and
my brother and he said I want to meet
these guys I don't know if he was an
idea or what it was something that he
saw that we were working on and he was
like I want to know about these guys and
I want to meet them and um and we were
reached out and I think it was the head
of his promotions Company Leonard
ellerby was like Hey like the champ
wants to meet you guys can you be in
Vegas I said yeah sure and we met with
him and
you did not say yeah sure you probably
were like stoked right like what was
your actual reaction to like hearing
Floyd Mayweather like wants to meet you
yeah I don't remember I don't remember
being crazy excited
it only hit me up I would be like if
Floyd hit me dude I don't even know my
mind would go blank I'd start panicking
yeah
what's crazy it's like just getting to
know him now it's like I get more
excited when he calls me now than ever
but uh because we don't talk as much
anymore
um obviously I've been busy he's been
busy so but um
yeah I just don't remember being crazy
excited
um it's just amazing how nonchalant you
are about like this career when she's
already tumultuous but also like
incredibly exciting you're making crazy
money at a young age very humble yeah
extremely humble skyrocketed to success
not Skyrocket I shouldn't say that but
like you know you grind it hard and you
did incredible things someone asked me
the other day it's like hey like what's
the secret to working with all these
people right like you name the person
I've worked with them or
did something with them or know them
right what's the secret and I think the
really secret is just like being
yourself like I'm myself like the way I
with you guys or anyone anyone I meet
you know anyone that you know a family
member or
Floyd Mayweather Kyle forjard you know
Logan Paul whoever it is like I'm I'm me
you know I mean like I don't really
change a lot of people I've seen people
be around them where like they're one
person and then they see someone of
influence or some sort of you know or
even Elon like I'm like I've got a great
relationship with Elon and I always
wonder like why why does he like I'll
get a random text or from him
and I and I'm just like dude I'm
probably like the only like ton of
normal person he knows everyone's
kissing his ass or pitching him on
something or whatever
um I picture my picture I'm on coming
back on full sent podcast part two like
you know but um but other than that what
she said he would do yeah he said it has
to be on Twitter spaces first so I gotta
come through on that how did you meet
Elon
met Elon
um
met Elon 2013 10 years ago I met Elon he
um he wanted to go to a Mayweather fight
this weekend maywether and um
and I was already going with to the
fight with Bieber it was Justin Bieber
and she said hey like if you and Bieber
want to come on my plane like would love
to meet you guys and you know we could
fly together and um believe it or not I
hadn't convinced Bieber to do that he's
like no it's good I'm good I'm I'll fly
on my own I'm like bro come on like come
on he's like he didn't really know who
Elon was like you know because the Tesla
was like out but like like you know him
as the guy who just sold PayPal you know
so
um
so yeah so yeah that's how that's how I
met him we went to a Mayweather fight
together now you have a funny story I
think you should tell it here about Elon
Musk and Justin Bieber on that flight
which part so the one where he was late
so yeah so some convincing this all
happened on the fights on a Saturday
we're supposed to fly out Saturday
morning and this all happened on a
Friday night uh my buddy shervin called
me and said hey like I got Elon Musk on
the phone I'm like okay and he's like
yeah we want to go to the Mayweather
fight tomorrow can you make it happen
and I was like actually we're leaving
with Bieber in the morning he's like
well why don't we all go together and I
pretty much said yes I spoke for Justin
I didn't think it would have to be
convincing so I was like yeah of course
we'd love that you know later you know
so so Justin didn't want to do it at
first so he just wanted to go on his own
like Justin's a very independent guy
he's Justin Bieber like no one really
impresses him like it doesn't matter who
it is like he's in his own world even
these days right he's in his own world
he just hangs out with his wife like
that's it so
um
so I I forgot the time it was like 10
a.m taking off and um
um I get there of course on time and
and elon's there already
My Brother Sam was with me shervin my
buddy good friend of mine who put the
whole thing together and then um
Justin's running late and I'm like
and calling him his phone's dead so I'm
calling security I'm like where are you
guys at he's like yeah we're like 20
minutes out all right all right and I
was like can I talked to Justin he's
like Justin's in the other car my other
car how many cars he's like oh we got a
couple cars and then I'm like oh God I'm
in the car like I didn't like I kind of
like I'm in the I'm like kind of low-key
freaking out but I'm like next to Elon
so I'm trying to play it because like
yeah okay I'll see you in a bit it's
like CM like 10 minutes later they roll
up
and I'm looking outside we're all on the
plane we're ready to go and it's two
three carve loads but there's only a so
Elon had his kids on the plane
um his lady at the time
um a couple other his brother Kimball
was on there
uh so the plane's already kind of packed
and Justin's rolling up in an Entourage
so I run out I'm like dude what's going
on he's like well didn't you say this
guy just sold PayPal
I said yeah he's like well what kind of
plane are we talking about here I'm like
bro like he's got his whole family like
you can't bring all your buddies like
and he's like all right well I'm leaving
I'm like no no no like please please
please so
um
so Elon comes out he's like hey
everything okay I was like yeah Justin
didn't know like how many spaces left
he's like well don't worry about it I
got another plane I'll have it here
right away
I might really he's like yeah it's like
another plan to be here in less than 30
minutes and he flew in a whole another
plane to fly all of Justin's friends Tay
James all these other guys
on on the second plane so how does he do
that though it's a must man he bought
Twitter for 44 billion I don't think a
second plane is going to be an issue but
that just seems absurd to being able to
call on the phone and have a private
Twitter 44 billion dollars did he not
care though was he just like oh yeah
that's no problem no
he's pretty stoic he's yeah very stoic
that was one thing I got out of him I'm
like like this guy like
like you know you know same facial
reaction like doesn't really you know
that's why on the full sin podcast it
was different you know he's like
laughing he's cracking jokes he's being
sarcastic like that was a different that
Elon I first met was like very like he
had shades on like he's like got this
like
what's Iron Man's name um Robert Downey
no no but the character um no oh Tony
Tony Stark he's got this like Tony Stark
like kind of like
Persona you know so um
yeah he's one of a kind how did you
begin working with Justin Bieber uh
around that time um you know he was
always kind of like the same way I
worked with Floyd like you just kind of
I think bounced off like my Creative
Energy and like we
um you know I told him about the company
who we had started at the time shots and
um the YouTube Network yeah uh this is
before we we launched an app shortly
later but he was really interested in us
being in the YouTube business wanted to
invest in the company he actually
invested he's the third largest
shareholder in the company behind me and
my brother uh to this day and he was
just like dude like what you're building
with YouTube like I love and I think
this you're on to something and I want
to be a part of it this is he was 18
years old
the other time and ever since then like
we've owned that company together we've
always been there together for like
different different things you know
um you know as a friend we've been there
together creative even when he was
making music he always like I was never
involved in this music business but if
he created Music he would send it to me
he's like hey just need your unbiased
opinion on this song and I was and I
would be the honest person this song's
fire I don't know about the song you
know then his team would call me why'd
you say you weren't into that song I
don't know he wanted my honest opinion
you know and there were songs that were
supposed to come out that like he killed
he's like no John he said he didn't like
it because he said no yes that was the
last Factor I'm sure he sent it to 10
other people but like maybe I was one
last factor or one of the factors but
yeah there were times when his team
would call me he's like dude he's
literally not coming out the song
Because what you said to him I just said
I didn't like it like you know I thought
maybe some of the other songs are better
wow so I'm a little confused from the
pivot from selling cable to going onto
this like YouTube
uh Network yeah like you had to be
successful at the YouTube Network in
order to get the attention from Mike
Tyson from Justin Bieber like how did
you like what was the actual Link in the
chain that got you in contact with them
was it just a successful YouTube now no
it was really Floyd So Floyd was the
first person who had heard about what we
were doing at DirecTV and all the
marketing stuff that reached out and
then once we started working with Floyd
um we launched Floyd's YouTube channel
you could probably look it up his first
video I think it was like 2010 uh Floyd
Mayweather was creating YouTube videos
um and then right around that time we
launched a kind of similar to what
fullsen is doing now with milk right
right one of the reason why fulson
exists and happy to use this is because
Brands aren't really keen on working
with milk so Kyle said [__] it I'll just
create my own Brands and ended up
working to his benefit and that was the
same issue with Floyd back then Brands
didn't really like working with Floyd
all too much so we started The Money
Team with Floyd So the money thing was
something that me and my brother and
Floyd created together which is his
clothing line now his brand as a it's a
brand that we had created together and
the same thing that kind of going back
to today that you know Kyle and I've
discussed is like you know are we going
to go chase around and try to sign a
deal with Reebok and Nike or under armor
or whoever or do we just create our own
brand that you actually own outright
which is what we did with Floyd and a
lot of people knew that a lot of people
in the industry said like who are these
two brothers that are doing all this
with Floyd on YouTube on social media
created The Money Team brand you know
and then we would always reach out to
people like give people kind of like we
do with happy Dad or full sense sending
care packages we send everyone these
cool care packages with the money team
and kind of we just developed this
relate this reputation of like like
these like
forward thinkers
um which in 2010 was like you know
creating a YouTube channel around
someone like Floyd was like very
different
um you know uh you know uh back then I
mean like music videos were kind of
newer to YouTube let alone like
celebrities creating original content
that's not seen anywhere else but
YouTube that was not normal in 2010. and
how are you getting paid because it
wasn't through YouTube at that point
were you getting money from the client
that you were working with you that's a
good question for the brand we made a
lot we made we made no money for a very
long time because the clients
didn't want to pay because they're like
dude where do I make money like and by
the way like why would I pay you people
pay me so that was their mentality
um yeah there was no monetization on
YouTube
um
we try to get Brands to get on board
um and sponsor videos
um
the problem with that was that Brands
would say like let's just say like a
company like Reebok said like hey sure
we'll we'll experiment we'll give you
five grand a video
you know three videos you know but how
do I go to Floyd Mayweather and say hey
I just got a fifteen thousand dollar
deal from Reebok when you know LeBron
James is making 10 million dollars a
year from Nike you know so like like I
like I didn't even know how to explain
that he's like dude I'm not endorsing
Reebok for fifteen thousand dollars so
so Brands you know friends were trying
to use us as the cheap way to get to the
celebrity that celebrity saw through
that didn't want to do it Brands
wouldn't want to spend more than like
whatever this little money that they had
to experiment so we were kind of left
out so we were like all right like we're
just going to not make money for a very
long time but build out this network
build out this reputation and it was
really until The Money Team launch when
The Money Team launched that would start
you know we created a Shopify site and
from day one started making money off
off that which was like you know pretty
much a joint venture between us and
Floyd so do you have ownership in The
Money Team yeah still to this day yeah
wow I have ownership in it and um
but also pretty much gave it to Floyd
and told Floyd because Floyd knows I'm
doing my thing and
just told Floyd like
thank you for everything
you got this like you know and he's got
a whole new team running it so I'm not
active whatsoever with The Money Team
um but yeah on paper I still
got ownership
do you still get royalties from that or
are you just like you know you take it
I'm going to focus on this thing here
honestly like maybe I'm entitled to it
but like sure you know it's not worth
the fact that Floyd gave me that chance
and like believed in me and my brother
and like like I always always always
whether he knows this or not I always
give credit to Floyd being the first
person to help me get into this business
Floyd loved me to Mike Tyson Floyd led
me to Justin Bieber yeah Justin Bieber
led me to milk milks led me to full sin
and happy Dad you know like but like I
always go back to like it was Floyd that
led me to meeting Bieber and Bieber led
me to meeting Kyle
Steve you know now what we have in full
sin and happy Dad yeah I found it very
interesting in a prior podcast you had
mentioned that you never burn Bridges
and you always keep the relationships
open because you never know where that
might lead oh no you never know it
doesn't matter who it is
um yeah you just never know I'm 43 years
old still people like 10 years ago like
that
come across I mean there's people who
burnt Bridges with me and I feel bad for
them but I don't I don't burn Bridges
because you keep in contact with so many
people and how do you like keep keep in
touch I I don't you know I mean I'm very
um
very focused on the business like I get
into the office very early my work days
start around 5 a.m
um you know sometimes I'll get in the
office around seven then leave go to the
gym come back around 10 10 30.
um and you know
um you know I mean at the end of the day
with everything I've done with
everything I have on my plate I still
only have 24 hours in a day like any
other person so I have to like figure
out what I'm going to focus on we have a
lot of employees and a lot of
responsibilities with our current what's
on currently on our plate so for me to
be this like social butterfly and go and
stay in touch with people I don't um
that's why I was saying before is like I
Wish I Still stayed in touch with Floyd
as much as I used to but like
like he doesn't you know he's doing his
own thing he's not a grandfather as well
I see all the time on social media he's
always hanging out with grandkid I'm
doing my thing but when we see each
other it's a big hug it's big like
surprise but but yeah it's just um you
know I don't really
stay in touch unless someone really
needs me for something like if someone's
like Hey listen like can I please like
sit down with you I gotta run something
by you I need your help with something
or some advice like sure come by the
office I got 30 minutes
maybe 15. so let's let's sit down but
like I just can't like just be out there
and just kind of hang out today was
different today I was like Hey like you
know other than emails I was like I'm
gonna hang out with my boys today you
know so today I kind of cleared my
calendar but usually like it's like go
go I have a lot happy that is is a beast
like happy that is not easy
um but it's I enjoy it so Floyd then
introduced you to Justin Bieber
meanwhile while you're running all these
connections and the YouTube Network
thing like you weren't really making too
much money it was The Money Team that
did that somewhere in the in the
timeline yeah you're then introduced to
Justin Bieber were you like his manager
what did you do exactly for Justin
Bieber business partner no scooter Bond
was always his manager
um
um no I was just a business partner we
sh um he invested heavily in the YouTube
Network shots it's called shot Studios
at the time now it's called shots
podcast network but
um he invested heavily so we were kind
of like just business partners on a
venture
um so we were kind of like
kind of like me and Kyle I'm not Kyle's
manager you know no Drew Hill's the
manager of milk you know I'm Kyle's
business partner was kind of the same
relationships just like we weren't
underneath the same
roof together
um you know because you know like here
it's a little different because like we
actually built an office Kyle works out
of the office I work at the office Kyle
lives 10 minutes from me it's a little
different here
um you know and and
you know and then drew the manager works
here we're all Partners together so the
dynamic here is a little bit different
than the relationship I had with Justin
Justin invested in the company was
Hands-On when we needed them but he also
had his music career his touring career
you know everything else that he has
going on it seemed like you were pretty
close with Justin as well like friends
as I'm like walking around this massive
Warehouse I see like a bunch of photos
with you like looks like you're
traveling with Justin hanging out with
him yeah we ended up being a very very
close friends as well
um you know we you know I mean there's a
yeah
12 or 13 year age difference I think um
maybe more but uh but we ended up
becoming like just really good good
friends like I think like it's like a
big brother little brother relationship
um you know he's an older brother but
he's the oldest so like I think like I
was kind of like the older brother to
him so it was more like buddy buddy
relationship they were there yeah there
were times that we would go to Fiji you
know for the weekend or I don't know if
we went to France we went to Dubai
uh we went to Oktoberfest and not in
Germany and was always like when we go
it was like we would spend three four
five days together and not talk a word
of business or just talk life you know
so it was like a big brother little
brother relationship I wonder what is it
like to travel with Justin because I
imagine he like can't be out in public
what's like Oktoberfest how do you how
do you manage that like getting them
through that Oktoberfest I think he
walked in no Mass no security it was me
him his dad Jeremy and his dad his uh
Jeremy's friend uh Andy and um that one
was like there was no security just the
four of us walking around Oktoberfest
and I think people like were like that
guy looks like Justin Bieber there's no
chance like like people were so shocked
that like people just didn't really
think it was him no mask no sunglasses
like it was at night but still like and
I think people are so wasted that I
think people are just like [__] I think
I'm [__] drunk because Justin Bieber
just walking around here like but and I
think the gnome did get approached
though there were some people that come
up to him yeah there would be some
people come up to them but um
actually I think there's a video online
[__] I forgot about this uh I don't know
how you look it up but um you guys do
that when you show them yeah yeah you
see a guy actually just started try to
start a fight with Justin out of nowhere
wasted
and I went and I just [__] took the
guy down like yeah yeah there's a video
online somewhere oh yeah when you walk
around without security no security but
why isn't that dangerous for him Justin
doesn't give a [__] man he just likes to
be normal yeah he isn't you know
yeah I mean his house has security like
if you know his tours have security but
sometimes he just wants to do normal
things you know there were there were
times like
he's always lived in LA but he would
just drive down by himself to my parents
house and just like hang out there were
times my mom would call me he's like
where are you at I was like um home why
he's like well Justin's here if you want
to come over we just ordered pizza he
would just like go to my parents house
randomly and just like
order pizza and uh just hang out with my
parents and eat pistachios and watch TV
like he just loves normal normal things
I would imagine that that sounds nice
after growing up like
in the spotlight to the nth degree right
yeah such intensity since he was just
like a little kid yeah right like his
that that's probably glamorized to him
in the same way that being so famous
that you can't show up anywhere is
glamorized to you know yeah for sure
yeah yeah we just took a like a two
minute bathroom break and during that
break we learned what did we learn well
hopefully he'll be back soon but uh
Instagram just removed Steve will do its
uh
account do you know why
um
it's not clear
we never truly know why you know like we
never even truly knew
why his um
YouTube went down
and I've heard a few different reasons
but
yeah
it's interesting that Instagram and
YouTube owned by different entities both
decide to remove Steve will do it now
I've heard certain conspiracies that
like all of them are in cahoots they're
all in the same like group chat you know
or there's some guy up top that's
running all these things what do you
think about that I think I think there's
a person at a platform that doesn't know
how to do their jobs so they'll just
read that YouTube did something and
they'll say oh maybe we should be doing
that too I think they're just
some sheep you think so yeah I think
that person there
that person that's making that decision
without properly doing their research
yes now
the sad thing is the people at
um these platforms that like run like
different worlds of the creators and
entertainment
uh they don't know those people so like
there's people at YouTube that actually
stick up for Steve and like call us and
say
we wish this didn't happen we have no
control like we love they talk to Steve
like there's some really that's why
you'll never hear me say anything bad
about YouTube because there are some
people that are really most people at
YouTube actually support Steve they like
Steve they like no they like the
shahidis uh but then there's just
somebody there and I I know I I know
this
at Twitter you know I'm not gonna I
can't really get into why I know this
but I know at Twitter it's like they're
not even employees at Twitter they're
contractors they're third-party
companies that they that Twitter and I'm
assuming that the other platforms do the
same as like they contract third-party
companies to run and you know kind of
look over the community and those guys
actually have the power and the
authority to do that so I don't think
they're like I don't think there's like
a group chat hey deleted Steve oh cool
we'll do that in a couple days too I
think it's like one does it and then
everyone's like oh well we got to do it
now too I think I got to do it because
you know my job is based off what
you know the latest tube filter article
talking about someone sells channel has
been restricted or taken down or
whatever
I'm just wondering what viewer of
Instagram sees that Steve will do it's
profile got deleted and they're like oh
yes you know what I mean finally like
they're sticking up there's got to be
you know yeah
Steve is a comedian and he's got a very
dark humor to his comedy so there's
somebody that just doesn't get his
community comedy and is taking it the
complete wrong way
and that's it's actually sad because
that's kind of the world we're in right
now we're like
you know and I I say this to Steve all
the time it's like somebody didn't watch
your video they just probably somebody
probably send them your video and said
hey fast forward to the 18 minute 20
second Mark and look at what he said you
know it's like and by the way
that's
that's probably the worst thing you
could do to me is send me a video and
say fast forward to 18 20 18 minute 20
minute Mark just send me the video I
want to watch the whole video I want to
know the whole context don't just tell
me to watch this one you know quick you
know one minute and judge the entire
video or judge your entire Creator I
want to know the whole story I want to
know the or in the case of Steve I want
to know the whole joke you know don't
just give me this one thing part of his
joke and make me assume that Steve said
something crazy or Steve is anti this or
anti that
um
so I think but we are in a world of
Clips we're in a world where Clips go
viral you know um even this podcast
right like there's probably gonna be a
30 second one minute part of this that's
going to go viral of something I said
and someone's gonna like me because of
it or not like because of it but that's
just kind of the world we're in where
like just Clips get taken and go viral
and Tick Tock or shorts or reels yeah
how do you get the account back though
um well
I just stopped I mean well you just saw
yeah what Jen just did is we just reach
out to the platforms like hey pretty
sure somebody made a mistake and someone
pushed the wrong button here you know in
the case of YouTube they're like no no
one made a mistake Steve's out
um
you know uh his Instagram has been down
a few times that's why I was saying like
by the time this is live it might be
back up we'll see
um you know his Twitter's actually been
taken down before and we we got that up
but um
yeah it's just um
you know we just reach out and say hey
this must be a mistake you know could
someone look into it got it Instagram's
very supportive uh Twitter of course
extremely supportive
snap supportive and
99 of YouTube is supported it's just
that one percent somewhere I don't know
where it's just yeah now I'll admit I am
extremely surprised that nelk is doing
as well on YouTube as they are I've
always felt from the very beginning that
they would be up against an algorithm
that maybe doesn't favor their content
that doesn't want to push uh you know
their let's say the The Parting
Lifestyle the drinking all of these
things are kind of against what
YouTube's guidelines generally try to to
push why do you think they've done so
well and do you think maybe there's a
person at YouTube is responsible for
like they like a certain Creator or
Channel and they flip a button and like
yeah let's
I do well the first part of it is I
don't think milk's doing as well as it
should I think nelk's views are really
coming from a very very hardcore
fan base because when we look at
um
the suggested and recommended views
they're far less than some of the other
channels that are underneath our Network
um
and
even even
um even you know I'll come back to
YouTube in a sec but even nelk on
Instagram like why doesn't why do note
boys only have four million followers on
Instagram for as big and powerful I mean
we're probably
arguably the most powerful group of
YouTubers like four million followers
like you know some you know but you've
got other Youtubers with tens of
Millions uh with not nearly the fan base
that nelcast so
um I don't think milk's doing as good as
milk should be I think what you the
numbers you're seeing are really
reflective off the hardcore audience
sharing
watching it over and over again
um embedding it onto their sites
whatever the whatever they're doing but
the K factor of the video is really in
the hands of our hardcore fan base we're
not getting the recommended and
suggested views compared to some of the
other channels and on top of that uh for
as many views as milk's getting
monetization's still not on the channel
but this channel still makes zero money
which is crazy to me a Channel at the
level of views that nelk gets right now
with a very very premium customer North
American male 25 and up
should probably be clearing a hundred
thousand dollars a month but don't you
think that's because of the copyrighted
music they use no they use the
copyrighted music because they know
they're not going to make money off of
it monetization
because of
what happened during covet when they
threw the party and YouTube demonetized
the milk and Steve will do a channel has
been off since so now they're just like
all right we're not making money then
we're just gonna put AC DC in every
video what about the full send podcast
that that that's been safe that makes
sense yeah yeah that makes sense that
makes sense right now
um that was started post that time
um it's a little bit different content
it's not branded milk boys
um
so yeah that was made about a year after
so that's been a little bit different
got it and then what about the question
of is there someone at YouTube or maybe
a group of people at YouTube who have
the influence to say I like this Creator
I'm gonna turn on views for them and get
their content recommended or turn it off
yeah yeah there is that I mean we saw
that with the Twitter files right like
there are you know there are people at
these platforms that say we're going to
mark this page as unsafe or this account
that is unsafe or as spam and we're
gonna Shadow ban it
um and on the flip side there's a
full-on I know this is a fact some of
these platforms have full on whitelists
there's like just recommend this at all
times recommend this everywhere I don't
care I don't care if they they're
watching a Rihanna music video recommend
this content after the Brianna music
video even if it's not relevant to
Rihanna music video How effective do you
think deep platforming is because I
remember hearing Tate say somewhere on
like some Tick Tock clip or something
like that he's like I am out more
powerful now than I ever was when I was
on you know Tick Tock when I was on
Instagram when I was on all these
platforms now I have much more influence
after they took me off because it was
like such a massive media thing like
when he got removed I don't believe that
you think D platforming is very very
effective I I think it hurts I think it
really hurts I think you've seen it with
a lot of people
no matter what it hurts and if you don't
if you don't believe me go look at
someone that's been deep platformed go
on Google Trends and look search their
name and how often they're searched on
Google before they were de-platformed
and after right the trends just go down
like they just make you pretty much
Disappear With Tate is that uh when he
was de-platformed originally it was all
anyone could talk about for like I would
I would say two weeks it's everywhere
and that's where I think he got that
initial Spike so temporarily I think it
does bring a lot more attention because
everyone who hasn't heard of him is like
oh who said Andrew take guy he got D
platform let me look into it but now
when you when you look at Andrew Tate
stuff it's not getting pushed anymore
and I think his uh his stay in Romania
or the the jail uh just got to extend
another 30 days and that's nowhere like
no one's even covering that anymore
right and there are no developments like
that's a huge development when he gets
de-platformed but then from there on
since he has no contact with everybody
through social media there are no
developers so nothing to talk about
people move on I think when you're not
creating new I think Tate is a little
bit different because it's so fresh yeah
and and he's not truly de-platformed
right like his Clips like he still has
this Tick Tock Army you know that's
really you know like this clip Army
right like that's like start on Tick
Tock but they're Distributing on shorts
and reels so he's still out there he's
still fresh but like let's look at like
some of the other guys like in the past
who are completely vanished like Vitale
you know like oh you got to give it a
couple years by the way I mean you know
Tate's only been the platform for six
months or so like and not fully D
platform right he just really lost his
YouTube and Instagram like he was back
on Twitter right away and and like I
said like but he's not really off
YouTube and Instagram because his Clips
Army is still strong it was Vitality
platformed I thought he just stopped
posting no I thought his YouTube got
deleted no it's still up there it came
back it was pretty sure
now you know what Vitality wasn't the
platform but Italian was blacklisted
which is all you know it was like the
old version of being D platform meaning
like nobody in Hollywood really wanted
to work with him
um same thing happened with Pewdiepie
for a little while yeah right he got
removed from his MCN
um I think it would demonetized or he
got kicked off Google preferred yeah
Luna I think he made an anti-semitic
remark
um so like eventually those things hurt
you in the long run but how do you
balance it because I know with milk
there's got to be a balance between you
know speaking their mind and being open
but also conforming to what the platform
is able to push because if you know nelk
were to do something it would also
affect happy Dad
well milk is also um
I think nelk has figured out a different
way to create content
um going back to that Dagestan Russia
video
right it was like to me that video was a
10 out of 10 as far as content goes
um
you know it was funny it was informative
it's educational it was behind the
scenes of a UFC fighter training for a
big fight with Islam and
um you know one thing that Kyle has done
a [__] fantastic job of is evolving
the content
to not not necessarily because of happy
Dad yes he keeps happy that back up his
mind because we are in a regulated
business but also he like knows that
like
what caused by 27 years old now like
he's like dude I can't be doing he says
all the time I can't be doing pranks the
rest of my life you know I gotta evolve
the content I gotta change up the fans
are older now they've been seeing this
stuff for a while I gotta I gotta change
the content but going back to where
we're talking about the social network
but without changing it drastically like
it can't be a sudden change has to be a
subtle change so there's some of these
videos of
yeah and also these um the audience has
been watching milk for a long time so
they just want to see what everyone's
been up to they want to see the behind
the scenes so
you know traveling to Israel traveling
to Pakistan traveling to Vegas or for
UFC or hanging out with Dana White the
audience wants to see that but also he's
like I can't hard cut to that so there's
been some pranks sprinkled here and
there you know there's been some funny
moments with like Hezbollah here and
there so there's laughter and there's
lifestyle in one now
um which is really I think he's done
such a great job of like kind of growing
up the content with the audience so it's
not the same thing so the contents
evolve quite a bit I think that's an
important thing for creators to learn
how much influence do you have on that
direction or are you supportive if Kyle
says I want to take this direction
um I would say I'm the influence I have
is kind of similar to going back to like
um the Bieber and music conversation
we're having is
I try not to get too involved with
creative but like Hill asked me like
what I think
and um
and I'll just give my honest opinion
like hey what do you think what do you
think about us going to Dagestan Russia
I remember when he asked me what do you
think about Russia like us going to
Russia like
dangerous but if you can nail it it's
[__] hilarious yeah that was my
opinion yeah you know weren't they
really scared of going to oh they were
terrified they were terrified man
I don't know if you submitted this I
think I heard him on a podcast
what was he on recently Bradley Martins
he was somewhere
uh
[__] I don't I heard Kyle some on a
podcast somewhere he spoke publicly he
was terrified who was the one athlete
that got the basketball player who was a
a prisoner there oh
um
I would feel like I would be terrified
they would you know find something or
look for something well I mean she took
weed yeah yeah like I mean not that but
I'm just saying like yeah she took weed
I mean they were extra careful when they
went
um
I heard someone told me that like they
were so clean that like they were
actually more
looked upon because everyone's like all
right what are you up to because you're
not breaking any laws and someone
someone I forgot I think Gabriel told me
like they thought they were spies
they're like all right wait a minute
like these guys are Americans and they
haven't done anything you know they're
Canadians but Canadian Americans and
they haven't done anything dumb what are
they spy so like they had like they
literally thought they were spies at
this point they're like why do these you
know Americans usually do something
stupid when they came here but they were
so clean yeah
but um
but yeah I mean it turned out great and
it's a 10 out of 10 video man like
that's my favorite that's my that's my
favorite note Boys video there's no goes
to Russia it is such a great video no I
loved it yeah I really like the behind
the scenes yeah
um but beyond that do you do you ever
pitch them ideas or or different
directions
um
I sometimes I'll throw something out but
I think Kyle
and Austin
you know salima chime in sometimes on
the milk video like they've got it like
sometimes I'm like I'll overhear things
like dude these guys make life so easy
like they've got it like sometimes I'll
like throw in something you know but
I don't really need to like these guys
got it um podcast idea like I'll
recommend uh podcast guests
um or even like maybe say like Hey
listen like this episode of the podcast
this is what's going on in the world you
know it's nice if you're gonna interview
this person but like sometimes people
want to hear about what's going on in
the world as well you know that might
get clipped up a little bit more like a
current situation in pop culture or
what's going on in the world or politics
um you know maybe remind him like maybe
bring that up so the podcast maybe a
little bit more or guests like
especially early on with the podcast
um I was literally just going down my
Rolodex I was like dude Mike Tyson I was
like shocked at the guests that you were
able to get on the phone unreal because
yeah unreal I loved the OJ video yeah I
was how did you get O.J Simpson on the
podcast
um dude O.J Simpson actually was
um believe it or not the OJ story was
Bob memory had reached out and dm'd OJ
um
and and he had connected his like
business manager I said talk to my
business manager so Bob's like hey talk
to the business manager
and um
and at the time like they were kind of
like not into it into it and
you know we were kind of toying with the
idea of maybe
the guys really wanted to do it like
they were like dude do whatever it takes
and we were toying the idea of maybe
like offering some money to get OJ on
and um and we were kind of talking about
this idea and then Kyle and I just
talked separately and we're like dude
like
we can never go down the path of paying
guests because that's just like
it's just gonna not end up good like you
know people are going to get your words
are going to go around and now like
everyone's gonna expect that I will get
in the mindset of paying so we didn't do
it and we kind of like stopped talking
to OJ's person for about
I don't know about a year
and then
um
OJ's guy called me
a couple months ago and I was like Hey
like if the guys want to do OJ like he's
in I was like Hey listen like we don't
have a budget or anything like that he's
like no no he's like he just watched uh
Elon episode there was three of them it
was Elon Mark Cuban
and one other one I forgot which one
um
I don't remember he's like he just
watched these three he was a football
player I want to say [__] I don't
remember
maybe Joe no it was someone more recent
uh but anyways he just saw these
episodes and like he's actually a fan of
the show like
so I called OJ I was like bro I got OJ
and these cows like we're not paying I
was like no like money's not even a part
of the conversation so I thought it was
so ballsy that he asked him well that
was the only way I mean Kyle and I were
talking about that we're like dude the
only way we could do this without
creating a platform for
what people think OJ did is um
you know just to ask like you know I
like we can't like you know like you
gotta ask and I was like yeah no [__] of
course I'm gonna ask yes four times
in different ways you know you disguised
this question but he asked four times I
loved all like the puns like yeah we're
gonna take a stab at oh yeah yeah yeah
I thought about something because they
were talking about like going out he's
like yeah we'd be a deadly Duo
I don't know I don't know if I'd had the
courage to like just write
um
right like you can't just like you know
tiptoe around that yeah every I'll tell
you what
I I check it out I um every
episode almost every podcast guest that
I booked I've been there for that person
yes episode whether I sat in on it or I
just sat behind like just make sure
everything's cool
that one I was like uh I think I have to
go to Atlanta sorry guys like I I just
saw I was like I I kind of needed to be
in Atlanta I could have canceled Atlanta
reschedule if I wanted to I was like no
no I'm not rescheduling I'm going to
Atlanta on a work trip sorry you guys
got this meet him in Vegas OJ had just
said like hey you know what I'm stepping
outside delete all the footage here
that's it like could he have done that
yeah and so how do you balance the two
of just like roll the dice man really
just roll the dice like there's a lot of
things you could have done he could have
[__] got up and
like you're gonna stab at it yeah yeah
you're gonna done that you could have
walked out you know he could have
you know you just
oh so what's your perspective on having
controversial guests on the on the
podcast
are there certain people that you would
deny to come on the podcast even if they
have a bunch of influence because
they're too controversial who would be a
controversial person to have on I mean
obviously we have Trump
I don't think you could get more
controversial than Trump or Tate yeah
and those he wasn't so controversial at
the time well the second time but they
never upload on YouTube which was the
weirdest thing gotta strike actually uh
yeah strike and a removal
on the channel today we were uploading
part two
um
which was like maybe a blessing in
disguise but so I think when it comes to
Jack and I um we're a bit on a spectrum
when it comes to who we want on the
podcast Jack is eager to take more risk
with guests and I'm probably too safe
and conservative like I want the guests
who like I really look up to who I
admire who I'm really interested in and
Jack's a little bit more of like that
you know what we should expand and get
people maybe who are a little bit edgier
people that knows I'm too eager and he's
too conservative like so who would you
who someone Jack would want that you
would want I want it on Andrew Tate when
and we were dming him we had like a back
and forth uh he was down to come on
Graham said no it's a little too sketchy
right now and then so much stuff
happened right like he like he got
arrested for a little bit and Graham's
like hi I told you so it would have been
a bad idea then he got released from
that and or investigated for you know
the thing and then and then I was like
hi I told you and it's the back and
forth with that that was one of them who
else had discussed there's been a few
other people that I've just felt like
they just seem a little sleazy easy to
me
um anyone in one name or no no
but uh Nico I was I was really down for
for a while Graham was a little opposed
to it but not super opposed to it uh and
then after exploring that more and
discussing it more Graham is now kind of
like he's like okay maybe that could be
an interesting episode my perspective is
if somebody has like a bunch of fans
they're
obviously saying something that people
want to hear right and I like to be the
type where I can hear out any
perspective no matter how extreme it is
because how do I know I'm right how do I
know my perspective Is Right without
contending it with
something else other perspectives and I
definitely think I'm too eager to the
point where I could have on people that
would be damaging to our reputation the
same way Graham is probably too
conservative where it's hard to Branch
out uh into different niches when we
just continue to do similar things on
the podcast yeah I would agree with that
I think the one value Tate would have
brought to you guys would be views but
outside of that I think you guys like
attract a lot different of people you
know I mean like your brand is a little
bit different than bringing on the
Andrew Tate in my opinion just kind of
like knowing your guy's brand and seeing
what you guys have done we definitely do
have a certain type of of brand on the
ice coffee hour it's most the time it's
like business minded people
entrepreneurs that have like made huge
businesses and stuff like that we don't
really talk about we've never discussed
politics we've never discussed like
social norms and and experiments and
activities and stuff like that with like
people like snico or something like that
that discuss that I don't know much
about snico honestly he's similar to him
he's he's very similar to Tate yeah
that's what I hear I've never seen a bit
of miscon we met him he came with
celine's birthday but I've I've met him
in person I've just never I don't know
anything about his brand so what do you
think about potentially branching out
and exploring more diverse topics uh on
the podcast yeah like I'll tell you my
goal by the end of this year is hit a
million subscribers and I'm like we're
gonna do that and Jack was saying well
if you want to do that we have to take a
more broad approach and get on more
controversial guests I'm open to it but
um but I feel like we could also do that
in a way that that we're spreading
messages that we don't have to like
rebuke like we don't have to come on and
like necessarily try to uh you know
pitch a different side to our guests or
try to like I don't want to say attack
but like really disagree with them if
that makes sense yeah um
like if I was your guy's partner I would
say yeah I don't even think you need to
go that route I think when I think of
you guys and what you guys have done is
the
controversy gets views no doubt right
Tate Trump
probably sneako I don't I haven't seen
this content but sounds like he does
um
but also like
I think what the world really needs and
what your audience needs and one of my
favorite things that happens with the
full sun podcasts at times is becoming
educational to that young entrepreneur
that people listen to you guys this is
why I wanted to do this when I want to
do this it wasn't necessarily to talk on
my relationship with Bieber and
Mayweather and Elk it was to talk about
how I started the business what it took
you know I mean me not being afraid to
just drop out with two weeks left to
start my own business you know obviously
my mom didn't like that like yeah I mean
like you know but now it's proven to my
mom like maybe that was the right move
um
and I think like I think that's what the
world needs right now more than anything
is like young entrepreneurs like us that
come out and educate someone to start a
business you know whether it's starting
a business a traditional business like
what I did or getting into the web three
space the nft space which is very very
early and people are learning getting
becoming a YouTuber um talked about this
once when I was on impulsive and then
obviously I got busy with happy Dad but
I still want to do it like one of my
dreams is to write a book on how to
write you know how to start a business
on YouTube and you know like yeah you
became a Creator but now what you know
you're going to be dependent on ads and
advertisers or you're going to build one
of these products because I think that's
the best thing that's what every
YouTuber should do you guys Mr Beast is
doing obviously Logan's doing it
obviously milk is doing it when Bradley
Martin's doing it with Roger and Zoo
culture
you know but like educating people that
like letting people know like this is
you know um I I I've heard this a few
times I have a lot of friends who have
kids and you know from age eight to like
12. you know the number one thing kids
say right now in school is I want to
become a YouTuber when I grow up you
know when I was in school I was like I
want to be a policeman I want to be a
doctor I want to be a fireman
it's none of that anymore I want to be a
YouTuber when I grow up okay what does
that mean you're gonna get views you're
gonna get subscribers
how are you going to make real money
yeah
um and I think that's what the world
really needs more than anything right
now doesn't sound sexy yeah I mean it
doesn't sound like it's gonna get 10
million views an episode
but I think at long-term rise it gives
you that credibility and I think that's
what really you know guys like Mark
Cuban who Mark Cuban had a Blog called
blog Maverick you know you put upload it
once or twice a week just by sharing
business ideas and those are like a lot
of the things in the early 2000s when I
was doing my DirecTV business that I
would
you know read and learn and I think we
need more people like that like what
Mark Cuban did for me when I was younger
what's one of the things that you've
learned from your guests like what's
been the most memorable like something I
learned from them or just something I
learned from the experience I could do
either one yeah just something that
sticks out to you I think Mr Beast
episode validated we knew that launching
happy Dad and what we've done with happy
Dad and what I was doing with Mayweather
10 11 years ago with money team is the
future of creators but like Mr Beast
just like straight validated it like we
just pretty much said this is the only
way creators are going to make it these
days every I think this and I've said
this a bunch of times I've said it on
podcast I've seen this here I say this
to friends every Creator is going to end
up
every crater is going to end up having a
podcast
and every Creator is going to end up
having a product that they own
you know I think the days of advertisers
on a podcast are going to be doomed I
think every Creator
um you know a podcast if you could
figure out a good conversation part
she's not that hard it's like talking to
a friend on the phone you know um if you
can figure out the good conversation
part you could have a successful podcast
and the hardest thing for creators has
been breaking onto YouTube
every creator has figured out Instagram
they figured out tick tock
you know um you know Twitter they've
kind of figured out you know Twitter's
not that hard just say something
um but YouTube's been very hard right
because before prior to this growth of
podcast the last four or five years the
only way to grow on YouTube was really
if you were a musician with a music
video a vlogger
or may like short films or comedy
sketches
um there isn't really no other like
creative vertical of content creating
and vlogging was very hard
short sketches
expensive and hard the music videos of
course you have to be a musician
podcasting is now made of like like I
like I've had I've had youtube.com John
for like 12 years
but I don't create content on there I
put my wedding video on there and like
some random shorts
you know but I've always liked dude like
what like why don't I have a YouTube
channel what do I do I'm not gonna Vlog
my day I don't have time for that I'm
not an actor I'm not going to make
comedy videos but I can make a podcast
if I really wanted to I could go and
launch a pocket I could pick three of my
friends we could talk about what's on
sports tonight and who we're betting on
or who we're you know picking on fantasy
and you know I mean like I could like
it's really easy for me if I really
wanted to I would ask you what
you know Mike's I should get how they
set this up or ask Oz guy to come help
me real quick you're right it's really
easy and for me now after all these
years of owning a YouTube channel to
launch a YouTube show of some sort so I
think a lot of more creators are going
to figure this out it's a lot more
easier than to do this than vlogging or
whatever else creators have been doing
over the years which ends up getting old
anyways
and and then how do you monetize that
well you're going to learn
from milk you're going to learn learn
from Logan you're going to learn from Mr
Beast to create your own product and
there's going to be more people like me
you're going to be able to find
where like you just find a business
person that's going to be able to figure
out how to make the right product for
your brand
and and create it and you become a
partner what would you recommend for us
in terms of a product I think coffees a
natural one but I've been doing coffee
now for two years and the margins are
really really Slim on coffee
um I would love to get into something
Finance related like some sort of money
saving app or just something like that
um but then I think to myself I'm not a
like my strength I think is YouTube
algorithm being on camera asking good
questions just that aspect of it I don't
want to split my time between that and
like trying to figure out a business on
the back end of that well that's why you
got to find someone to run the business
and you do a joint venture of some sort
with them you know whether it's like a
50 50 partnership and say Hey listen I'm
gonna be
the media side of this brand you're
going to be
the product side of this
and and let's go make something together
um you know uh there's a lot of
of um there's there's a lot of different
markets you could tap into right like
like we want to
happy Dad the company wants to own
what's inside convenience stores like
that's what we want to go after like
we're going to create other products
down the road we have happy Dad now
we'll probably have uh we have our um
our beef jerky brand board jerky you
know uh maybe one day we'll have a
non-alcoholic beverage
maybe we'll get into things that are at
the counter at the checkout stand
lighters or probably not Vapes I'm not a
big Vape guy but maybe cigars you know
like like whatever's in a gas station
convenience store or grocery stores what
we want to own but I think though those
are like you know you got to just kind
of look at
what what it's really what you got to
find a balance between what your
audience wants and what you're
passionate about
Logan's an athlete KSI is an athlete
made sense for them at the sports drink
so from your experience being on the
iced coffee hour you also mentioned that
you think everyone's going to come out
with a podcast how do we level up and
make sure that we're ahead of the curve
and we stay ahead of the curve here
got to find out what your uh
your the main vertical topic is
and just own that dominate that Niche
yeah yeah just dominate that age we were
talking about that actually me and Jen
were talking about that the other day is
like
you know like
someone could create a
you know
recently divorced podcasts and just
owned that yeah I mean like there could
be wedding you know getting married soon
podcast all the things you need to do
about getting married and like you know
having like you know you know Brides
that are you know have their wedding
coming up and their experiences on like
ordering catering ordering the DJ venue
flowers all this you know I mean like
just so many different verticals of life
that people could talk about
um you just have to own that and it's
not the same thing you know I think like
I think it's more about the topic than
it is like having guests giving getting
guests helps take maybe pressure off of
you because they could bring you things
to talk about but they don't it's not
necessarily about the guests in my
opinion that's interesting because one
of the biggest pain points for us on the
podcast are getting consistent high
quality guests now you're saying that
that isn't the most important thing it
is not why is that because we found that
if we have a guest who either has a name
they're known people are searching them
or they have a really really cool unique
Story the videos do substantially better
than if we get a no-name person where
their story is a little meh uh even if
the conversation is great if people
don't know them and we can't convey a
reason to click on the video or watch to
begin with it it does worse
it certainly helps if you have a guess
because now you use that person in your
title thumbnail and you're tracking
Their audience because YouTube is so
smart that'll find people who are
interested in that person and drive
their traffic to you is just more
pressure on you because like now if you
don't have a guest this week you know
find anyone what are you gonna do not
upload because you're dependent on the
guest
um you know you got to figure out kind
of the balance yeah it's nice to have
certain people but don't be dependent on
a guest because what's worse than not uh
than not having a guess is not uploading
I just think the utmost or like the the
equilibrium between like frequency and
quality kind of right there lands at
once a week and of course if there's
some sort of event or something that
happens such as Graham's fight in the
Creator Clash that was a super cool
event we're not going to reserve that
for a Sunday we could do that all
in-house just us and then sure on that
occasion yes we can post one in the
middle of the week yeah
um but leave that up to other things
that could potentially be happening and
if they're so exciting we have to talk
about it we'll do it but if we adhere to
some schedule where oh every single
Wednesday we have to release an in-house
podcast episode yes we will run out of
things to talk about and for me it's
really hard to put something out there
that I don't feel 100 confident in is
like yo I don't want to be wasting
people's time with this like I want them
to tune in and be enthralled every
minute you know yeah well
that's why you're a great content
creator too right like as content
creators you guys are directors and
editors right so you're directing what
you're creating and you're editing at
the end you're going to figure out what
what is great out there and and yeah I
mean you're not afraid to think
great content creators are not afraid of
ways throw away
content either
doing a lot of things Kyle I've seen I
do so what happened to that footage yeah
it wasn't good enough really like we
went all the way here and there spent
all this money yeah it wasn't good
enough you guys ever shoot podcasts and
not post them yeah yeah yeah it's a sore
subject but yeah there was one
can you say who you can't yeah well
Steve said it and steiny got mad that
Steve said it so that's the only reason
I want to say it but there was an
episode with Andrew Schultz and uh whoa
and um
man sorry Steinberg man I love you bro
like Donald don't text me middle of the
night upset but
Sheltering after like you know I think
you know when like a stand-up comedian
like looks in a crowd and decides like
just go after somebody well I think like
Schultz was kind of like went out to
steiny and he um
and it was pretty awkward was it the
whole episode or was it like it was a
bulk of it it was like no you couldn't
cut around it or he would come back to
it and like he just wanted to go after
steiny all of us felt bad for Steiner
like damn like you know I was like I
know that feeling it's like I've
actually I was at a stand-up show yeah
Dave Chappelle a long time ago when he
was first coming and he he decided a
small place improv here in Irvine I
don't know
2000 2005 2006 I don't know a long time
ago Dave Chappelle was on a come-up
blown up then um
foreign
just eyed me and just the whole show was
just roasting me roasting me what was he
saying I had a big beard at the time and
it was like a couple years after 9 11.
so he's like we found them you know like
yeah like bro he was going ah you know
everyone's laughing like how'd it feel
for you I love Dave Chappelle still oh
yeah I felt cool no no at the time I was
like you know almost all my buddies
they're all laughing but they were like
but the thing with my buddies that are
still my friends like they all like we
all roast each other anyway so it was
like just felt like one of them was
roasting me so at the time I was like
that yeah like why me but like honestly
like then after that like just watching
Dave Chappelle come up I was I was like
all right like
I love Dave Chappelle all right that's
like a badge of honor right there no I
still hated it I I don't even talk about
it like I bring this up like once every
like five years I remember I tried to
like get it out of my memory but so
going back to steiny is like I felt his
pain a little bit
um you know it's just like so anyway so
that episode
he was just like not happy about it and
this never really came out so did he
like veto the posting of it you know at
the end of the day it's Kyle's decision
um
but
I think it was just one of those things
where um just don't want to deal with it
we're just like you know what uh there
was someone else that we interviewed
right around there and we're like we'll
just go with that episode I forgot who
it was
but it was like a big man big name and
we're like well we'll just go with that
one instead I remember when it was was
it December so whenever the December
uploads were
was a big name but interesting huh but
that was the only reason I get that
though I don't think you necessarily
want to make anyone feel bad or or you
know cause anything steiny yeah one
thing about steining
it could be a little [__] sometimes
but he also
does a lot for the company like he he
really does a lot like he introduces us
to Partners he helps with the podcast a
lot you know he came in and he helps
with the podcast behind the scenes and
then he came in during a time where Kyle
needed a consistent solid co-host and
helped stepped in there helps with the
creative helps with questions which is
part of the behind the scenes stuff
helps book guests helps even with me
like
like don't you know this person yeah
kind of he's like well can you get them
on the podcast I'll see what I can do
right he'll kind of help like kind of
give me a little layup so he actually
does a lot for for the podcast Steve's
assistant for a while right he was yeah
I liked his whole come up story I
listened to all of his podcasts too like
he tells the story of like working for
Steven doing anything like two o'clock
in the morning Steve wants something
he'll drop everything and he'll get it
done even if it means he's not sleeping
at all like I love that sort of hustle
and that sort of mindset that you'll do
whatever it takes just to make it work
he's definitely a go-getter yeah um he
and I don't always see eye to eye we
always uh argue but um what do you guys
argue about anything like he just saw
you know he goes to these middle of the
night Rants and um
and I don't like middle of night rants
like don't text me in the middle of the
night please uh don't take them about
anything don't text about anything good
or bad just don't text me in the middle
of the night and he'll just go through
rant sometimes
so then I wake up ideas or no like
ah I don't really know I try to Black it
out you know um he just you know he just
has his moments okay but I appreciate
that guy so I'm curious because you seem
so knowledgeable in so many things and
like almost like an expert in all of
these fields what do you think your weak
points are what you were asking about if
I ever give the guys ideas
and um
you know I don't think that's my Lane as
much as I'd like to because I love
everything we do I love the videos but
like sometimes you know think of
something like damn I wish we could do
this but then I'm just like nah these
guys got it like I just I'll just sit
I'll just have that idea in my head but
I just I think that on the creative side
um
milk is milk because
99 out of 100 ideas come out of Kyle's
head and I just leave it at that because
milk's got to remain milk
and that one out of 100 might be an idea
that like
steiny or Steve or Saleem or Austin gave
them you know and maybe maybe it's less
maybe it's 80 20 but whatever it is I
just stay out of that because these guys
know what they're doing what milk was
doing before my time worked and what
milk's doing post my time as far as
content works like my Lane is to build
the business to protect the business
um so I just kind of stared that I try
not to get you know you know I'll walk
by the conference room sometimes
there'll be a meeting and someone will
wake me in I'm like what are you guys
talking about next idea is what you got
anything and I'll just walk out like no
I don't have anything I'm just going to
go back and you know just let me know
when the video is going live I'll make
sure everything's okay on the business
side but I think that would be
a weak point I think
um
you know it's also a strength though
because you're also recognizing where
your fault is and how you're not going
to interject yourself in conversations
that you can't provide value in well
yeah but I think it was a weak point
before because maybe in the past I used
to insert myself into the creative side
of things whether it was with melkor not
necessarily it's not what people are
working the past and I've kind of
learned like
don't do that don't get involved with
the creative work on the business
um you know another thing was like what
Jen said is like taking on too much but
now I've learned higher like just hire
people and fully train you know when we
hire people here
they have one job and one job only and
that's their role there's no do a little
bit of this and a little bit of that you
know some people believe in like hiring
uh Swiss Army knives someone that could
do a little bit of everything I believe
in like hiring machetes like do one
thing and one thing only like your job
like we have one guy that works for
happy Dad
she came on board and her job is to
service 711 and 7-Eleven only
the other day I was driving by Chevron
you know they have the extra miles and I
went in and we're not in one but I've
been to a couple we are so we're not
inconsistently all the Chevrons so I was
thinking do I call Kylie and tell her to
check on
Chevron extra miles at Chevron but
um I like nah let her focus on 7-Eleven
let's fire hire someone else just for
Chevron let's hire someone else just for
Circle K just plain of these locations
to pay for them for the person as a
salary
um to you know to compensate the salary
so so that's why I think like something
I've learned in the past before is like
let's have everyone do everything even
General she came on board she was doing
a little bit of everything and you know
everyone now it's like I think when
you're hiring someone just give them one
job and let them be great at that don't
give them a little bit of too much
because then they're going to drop the
ball on something else and you're not
going to be happy and now you did a
disservice that person because now
you're not happy with their performance
you're going to let them go and fire
them and then it's kind of [__] up on
your end because you didn't properly
train that person and now that person
lost the job because you didn't properly
train them or educate them on their role
so that's something else that I've
learned is like when we hire someone
just give them one job and one job only
let them be great at it if they're done
by 5 PM go ahead go home don't don't say
like oh they didn't I don't have enough
give them a couple more things so they
stay late night like like I do no
they're done by 5 PM they got the job
done everything's done great
great let them go home so how involved
in management are you management of
employees Barry very that's probably my
number one task is working with our
employees how do you learn to be a good
manager and what do you think a good
manager does I think exactly what I just
said I think
um
you know
ing before you hire the person knowing a
role that is necessary to help the
company with growth whether it's you
know
growth and product or growth in Revenue
um or really both and then find someone
that could fill that role train them on
that role and let them focus on that
role in that role only eventually
they'll be great at that role and that's
and then eventually then you have some
people then you group these people up
and you build teams and then because I
could only
happy dad's got near you know over 50
employees now
I can't talk to 50 people all day every
day so now I have
five direct reports and these guys have
teams underneath them assume we'll have
state leads for every single so the
representatives in each state will
represent it will reach out to the state
lead and the state lead will reach out
to the National lead in a national lead
reports to me but I think like you know
splitting up these roles and letting
people be focused on one thing and one
thing only is very important how do you
decide when to cut somebody now we have
a very very low turnover
um
I think if somebody doesn't do the job
that I'm saying and doesn't really
well if someone doesn't do that job and
it's not the right fit we'll give them
two to three other rules first and try
to get them to fit into one of those two
or three other roles and if they don't
get to probably the third then they're
just not a fit for the company but we
will give people up to three different
chances
um I'll start them at this one roll
let's just say this person I worked at
the seven level she she crushed it from
day one she's crushing it now but if she
didn't work out with 7-Eleven she's not
great at talking to store owners retail
store managers so maybe we would give
her another position and move her to
e-commerce maybe she would be
responsible for putting products on
amazon.com
if that didn't work then maybe we would
move her over to helping
build podcasts and build
that we're going to get into like the
country music podcasting pretty soon and
like you know we're building a studio in
Nashville I'm going to have a whole
studio there for Nashville and Country
genre podcast move her over to that role
completely different role if that didn't
work okay she's just not sure capable of
working here and how do you balance the
business and you're also newly married
how do you balance that and you know
making sure that everything's fine at
home family speaking I have dinner
tonight yes um
well the good thing is she has got a
full-time job during the days as well so
when I'm working she's working she works
for a company called Irby that
um completely different world but
um
there are these really cool like
lifestyle hip apartment complexes
um she's the head of recruiting there so
she's got her she's and this company is
growing like crazy so she's very busy
there
so during the day it's like it's fine
like I'm working she's working then when
I come home
um we both like to go to bed early so we
just grabbed dinner together and go to
bed early we wake up early spend the
mornings together and then I head out
come to work but the weekends are just
for us you know I try not unless I'm
traveling with the boys for something
that's really important like a new state
launch or
um usually usually a new state launcher
or something happy Dad related
um
you know we just I just make sure that
times I got with her is I'm off my phone
spend the time with her so what's next
for happy Dad
so we're right now we're in 16 States
we've been really focused on just really
optimizing those States and growing the
penetration building out of sales staff
that actually goes and meets the store
owners store owners at the end of the
day like they want to meet
the
the brand like they don't want to meet
you know we have a lot of middlemen in
our Distributors
um the people who work for the
Distributors uh but they they you know
the store owners want to meet someone
that walks in with a happy Dad shirt and
a happy death card and they want to meet
the end product so we're building out
that team right now
um
so we're currently in 16 States we're
going to be launching five more
uh
and and then we're gonna be launching
Canada so we'll be in 21 states
in Canada
um
and we'll just be really focusing on
like being great in those States and
optimizing and you know building out the
sales team getting into bars getting
into restaurants
getting into all types of
different
um
stores from gas stations to convenience
stores
grocery stores Club stores Costco Sam's
Club the happy Dad model to me
you know a lot of
those who don't know us say like you're
the next white clock truly no
those who think they know say you're the
new next Budweiser no
to me the model I've always looked at is
Pepsi Cola
you know I've always been inspired by
Pepsi Cola that model you know Pepsi
owns Pepsi Pepsi owns Gatorade Pepsi
owns Frito-Lay and all the different
chips underneath the frito-layer
umbrella up until recently Pepsi owned
Taco Bell KFC Pizza Hut
so
you know Pepsi doesn't only own Pepsi
like they own all these other brands
that you know you know 99 of the world
would know that these Frito-Lay Brands
Ruffles and you know um you know Doritos
and all them are underneath that
umbrella
um 99 of people don't know that Gatorade
is owned by Pepsi
and that's kind of like the model that
we want to go out there it's like but
the end end the end product is Pepsi
like they really care about Pepsi sales
more than anything else they just you
know the other ones complimented
um and I've always looked at kind of
happy Dad the same way it's like happy
Dad to us is our Pepsi
and we'll be launching our beef jerky
line and that to me is our Frito Lays
that's our that's our chips
um you know um soon
will be
optimizing our you know our like
nutritional side of things
um
with like
the full sense supplements business and
that to me is our Gatorade the future of
happy dad is really the beverage more
flavoring
more more States
more feet on the ground
and more Brands underneath the happy Dad
umbrella the big business is like
building Ventures together and what is
the next brand underneath happy dad
never know maybe a holder pitches us on
a
vegan potato chip that tastes great you
know like oil is vegan and made with
olive oil whatever it is
yeah
cool
thank you so much for doing this yeah
seriously you love being here so much
time you're very generous with that yeah
I appreciate it I gotta go it's cool
well thank you again yeah of course
appreciate it I'll link to all your info
Down Below in the description yeah
belong to you guys thank you cool thank
you guys for watching really appreciate
it until next time I want to make sure
we're not putting you behind yeah